yeah welcome to this video a blitz game
and I'm playing a grandmaster with the
German flaky Accord called Ebert Eva had
this a German name and it's a rather
old-fashioned name but one thing's clear
this guy's got 2,600 he's not not bad at
blitz so let's see what happened
unfortunately you've got a group at
which is not my strongest suit in terms
of theoretical knowledge so there's some
line that I could play that that is not
them not so theoretical or some some
safe stuff don't really know maybe add
try form for fianchetto set up this is
really high since the 2600 and the
German German flag and German name of
courses can all be just down some
deceptive ploy to to irritate people ok
he's played this quick Knight b6 knight
c6 p.m. and i think there are positions
where you can actually sacrifice the
pawn i'm not sure if this is the case
IAM i really don't know the line I'm
time maybe I must play through III am I
don't know no that's a 585 I think hmm
this is so it just what I know from
watching some games and some grand
master games this has been played in
recent years some ideas like we should
use six Bishop c4 but he's retreating
all the way back interesting this
actually I know I think it looks good
for white maybe yeah I'm misjudging this
position it's possible of course a 3m as
maybe am the IDM to undermine the the
night so possible on reply here's of
course night deform yeah maybe I should
do that to make sure that this a3 move
is not on yeah all right but now I don't
unnecessarily need to take I can also go
night to be five maybe I'm this is more
more interesting so he's probably
threatening to take and play a three so
I'm i go out of i leave the sum diagonal
a1 a1 g7 we have the position here um I
think cannot be too terrible for me I
mean don't think I made any any
substantial mistakes or something
considering that i don't really know
this position type it's not bad but his
plate quicker something
yeah the kind of strange maneuvers you
have in the goon fault sometimes maybe
he's intending work to be six simply
possible I'm five I would like to play
e5 okay let's just develop rugby 6i can
also drop back to a 3mm lambda try to
play you five this is Wow ya don't mind
you to go back here unless I'm
blundering something this is certainly
an achievement that I can get back and
play e5 nexans yeah I actually suspect
that whitis has a big advantage here
he's got 30 seconds extra but the
position is very good for why'd you know
this is some strong strong measures you
need to you felt the need to were to do
that ok but maybe not sure I Pusha page
6 is really leading to something ok
let's let's do this first before prevent
before and down he can go nite be three
but it's not not such a big deal I hope
that he needed to or at least he felt
the need to to give up his his dark
squared bishop it says of course huge
for wide
I've got a very very weekend King side
now I want to push up push a five and
may be deemed e6 we need to be cautious
that time Wow yeah maybe you want to
drop back to f7 but let's let's make
sure that I get the position opened up
yeah of course you can try to attack
here the the the rook so um maybe just
take I don't really mind might exchange
on b1 want to make progress here taking
this pawn maybe or getting to e7 he
takes with the pawn so what now Knight
takes be 54 or should I actually am save
the exchange I can take you
I take the 60 and it takes the exchange
I know the light squares maybe you can
take Adam okay this is interesting f to
Scott of2 attacked ah this is this is
annoying but not much that I can do if
it takes with the rook now I can give
this check and play 94 maybe text with
the Queen I can take c4 look f1 on what
else if i take 92 is the problem so
let's go here
yeah of course I didn't look at this
movie yeah oops not a pre move please
yeah of course I'm lost gem be some
grating getting be too yeah I don't know
this was a weird game I think I'm the
kind of this the kind of position of
that I'd love to have against this
person in the tournament game and I
think he will lose very badly then but
it's a tricky and tricky and blitz chess
of course yeah come on don't really have
any trick here yeah this is this
position is winning for white probably
are very very very very better I mean
I'm actually afraid to switch on the
computer it's just 11 porn come to the
computer but it's it's really terrible
computer wants to bring the night to
before and Bishop e3 so just the
positional way to play and this is very
strong actually just stay calm the the
five move um is of course very direct
and the question is if it is really good
of course I didn't instead of here you
see five wins according to computer okay
yeah it's not much of a surprise really
yeah and now okay he said I didn't
didn't really think about that then I
lose and lose an exchange but this is
not such a problem really i think the
real problem is that i took now I wanted
to have concrete play against b5
and what if I just just play on with an
exchange down something like this yeah
this is actually interesting in this
position here the computer um here gives
black almost an advantage of a pawn and
this sir is some trillium yeah computer
like evaluation because I think white
has some quite good compensation at
least in a gamer amongst humans because
blacks got a very weak King this Bishop
is very strong and there I did these
kind of ideas which baby can be defused
but then it's not easy and this would
have been much trickier for black to
play takes of these 61 so good you're
right an interesting game thanks for
watching